cordillera de todo seguro de screen
urban garden des cadeaux Dutch going to
the snare call me kuchu mr. on there are
no desk theory was ok Carboni snog
absolute avoca optimist yes Omaha
attention memory forever gable is only
turn engine to me a cigar nah no hado
promote my vagina afterwards it was me
against 50 of the Living Dead I liked by
gypsies americano yepper a zombie a
guitar so the committee to go univ r
rajkumar termina suppor skirt showed up
with each time
well the arts half of the game is
fundamentally non-realistic wanted to do
something graphic and stylized strongly
stylized in a way that we don't think
we've seen in games before and that has
allowed us a lot of freedom to go very
very kind of exaggerated in the action
Balika Vadhu content to his own eco you
more 33 date abilities to that back to
complete product a hygienic Oh soon
occur near nah idiot a smart or visually
poor and those naughty naughty I'm gonna
try the car I'm like whoa emotionally
physically and I know their support for
the notice casaya harder son oh you whoa
not total game to get other side of it
today from this title to talk at all or
they are the distance you know large
explosions too small to character
effects that go up most of that is
actually hand-painted cell by cell you
know within the comic book kind of style
you really have to paint it and take
your time and attention to detail
basically rip off body parts and off
Asami's to use as weapons each character
in our game has a unique weapon the
other than harvest program will we have
a character where you rip off his arms
and they become farmtruck's
Comfort song massage of it myself its
geography time
need not civil additional death
oh yeah it's good
ninja gaiden sedated for you I'm song
game cause motto barato my game on Scott
able to thank you I know how they are
planning food I feel sorry for you
topper on szigeti to a masculine combat
it's gruesome and effective and there's
blood everywhere the score you jib
enemies in the first line it just looks
like mayhem oh no character toggle
donahoo Nico zombies attacked a sec I
was good pika no computer carro y batata
money poor aunt Ayano political panel /
saturday Sangha oh mama de Soto Street
optica George Scott almost a ninja oh ma
we keep kosher clear akhtar to stick on
cable once we should i cancel right then
that's what yeah but really is it's
taking all the cool things that are
ninja guiding and doing them at their
full extreme automatically we don't
revolve lots of iterations to discover
where the interesting intersection
between the ninja and the zombie it by
ninja recruited Adam why must she is
only a kind of butter on there so no
telling what is there and what I never
got the broken I cannot why must they
eat toxic oh [ __ ] awareness whoever
ruining my [ __ ] pants apart
oh no y dejemos interview cerritos
canary oh sorry tío Tomas Tomas I gotta
quiero llegar a tu lugar donde my banana
nose en Austin out oh my mosquito
tomorrow tomorrow my dear our opposition
wha you have said anymore yeah our
material they usually used on my bus he
taught at the panera bread